on du bilan 86 88 du gouvernement chirac
le document de 40 pages peut être
résumée en trois mots liberté
redressement et solidarité les faits a
dit jacques chirac sur notre antenne
hier soir sont incontournables
aujourd'hui les barriste ne veulent pas
porter quelques critiques que ce soit à
l'encontre du bilan je cite leurs propos
par contre vives réactions côté
socialiste et communiste georges
marchais qui était l'invité du journal
d'antenne de ce midi quand même beaucoup
plus loin il critique
l'ensemble du septennat lorsque l'on
prétend que ce septennat se traduirait
par une amélioration de la situation des
françaises et des français
c'est tout simplement scandaleux les
gens ne savent bien
pour certains oui mais pour les gens qui
vivent du fruit d'un travail
ce n'est pas vrai il ya plus de chômage
plus de difficultés à vie et des
attaques contre les droits sociaux des
gens voilà la réalité
de 1986 à 1988 la france a perdu cent
mille emplois et le chômage augmenter
malgré un traitement social à forte dose
en août il a aggravé les inégalités
sociales et aujourd'hui plane sur notre
économie
beaucoup d'incertitudes c'est la raison
pour laquelle je trouve ce bilan une en
pur moment électoral quoi c'est celui
d'un candidat à la présidence de la
république
c'est un bilan utile et qui est exact
mais on aurait dû le compléter sur deux
points je crois premier point voir où on
se situe dans la compétition par rapport
à nos partenaires européens
on aurait vu par exemple que pour les
prises étaient bien mais pour l'emploi
on continue à prendre du recul les
anglais ont créé deux cent trente mille
emplois ne nous avons perdu 50 mille
emplois et je leur ait complété sur un
deuxième point qui est de prendre la
perspective
regardez sur deux ans c'est trop court
pour juger de la situation de la france
il faut laisser temps or l'enjeu
l'enjeu majeur des prochaines années
c'est de remonter le handicap accumulée
pendant les sept années où nous avons
pris un recul considérable par rapport à
l'eau à nos partenaires l'équipe de
campagne du parti socialiste au grand
complet pour l'atome